[Musique]
- deux députés - deux mandats de la
proportionnelle c'était une promesse du
candidat macron il veut manifestement
aller encore plus loin en accélérant le
travail parlementaire c'est donc un
débat très politique que nous ouvrons
ici à la brasserie des loges dijon qui
nous accueille avec un député la
république en marche bonjour bonjour
élus de saône et loire benjamin dire que
c'est votre premier mandat
mr les républicains de beaune alain
suguenot bonjour vous maîtrisez
parfaitement les arcanes du parlement
après 15 ans passés au palais bourbon
comme député de côte-d'or grain sylvie
beaulieu bonjour vous êtes la secrétaire
départementale de codeurs du front
national vice-présidente du groupe au
conseil régional bourgogne franche comté
et arnaud ghislain natale bonjour
bonjour vous représentez ici la france
insoumise de jean luc mélenchon tout à
fait puisqu'on est dans un café on va
évacuer le cliché de comptoir il y
aurait trop de députés trois sénateurs
ils coûtent trop cher ils ne font rien
alors on va essayer d'aller au delà
est ce qu'il faut modifier nos
institutions et pourquoi benjamin dire
ça marche pas écoutez je crois tout
simplement déjà c'était un engagement de
campagne d'emmanuel macron réduire le
nombre de parlementaires la
proportionnelle ces engagements là bas
comme vous l'avez remarqué depuis le
début de notre mandat et bien d'autres
dans tous nos engagements nous allons
continuer comme cela
quand vous étiez député alain suguenot
vous l'entendiez déjà trop de députés
on se demande ce qu'ils font une coûte
cher il faut changer des règles ou pas
ce discours là on peut l'entendre par
turbo pose la question à des personnes
qui ne vivent pas l'avis du député ou
qui ne savent pas comment fonctionne
aujourd'hui deux institutions
le vrai problème par contre c'est que la
proportionnelle vous le savez depuis des
années je fais partie d'une famille
politique et qui continuent d'ailleurs à
se battre contre ça parce que le système
majoritaire est le seul système qui
parle de la majorité regardez l'italie
et même l'allemagne c'est quand même pas
évident sur les erreurs des uns devrait
servir de leçon aux autres
arnaud granata on va détailler un peu
mais c'est de la cosmétique de la 5e et
c'est en tout cas pas une sixième par
rapport à ce que eux
alors effectivement par rapport à ce
qu'on a défendu à l'élection
présidentielle c'est à dire un régime
parlementaire la mise en place d'une
assemblée constituante
on n'est clairement pas sur 7 sur cette
dynamique puisque évidemment le
président macro
renforce le pouvoir hégémonique du
président de la république en diminuant
le pouvoir du parlement
les arguments sur la limitation du
nombre de députés seraient pour la
facilité et l'efficacité du travail
parlementaire mais en réalité ils ont
pas ils n'ont pas besoin de ça
finalement ils ont déjà une majorité
pléthorique qui font déjà passé tout ce
qu'ils veulent ils peuvent avoir recours
aux ordonnances donc la question de
l'efficacité de la rapidité du travail
parlementaire est pour moi une fausse
question moi je pense qu'on est plutôt
dans un climat très anti parlementariste
et de défiance vis-à-vis vis-à-vis du
politique et ça c'est je pense un
problème quand on est aux
responsabilités qu'on est présents de la
république on voit on va y venir
c'est du beau lui cette réforme là elle
était demandée souhaité ou pas par elle
est souhaitée par marine le pen nous
sommes plutôt pour le triptyque communes
départements et nation donc bien
évidemment avec moins d'élus nous
reviendra pas sur le cumul des mandats
mais par contre le moins de moins d'élus
oui les 300 députés 200 sénateurs nous
ça nous va tout à fait alors ce sera un
des points que un des points qu'on va
aborder mais dans ce projet ce qui est
important tout de suite c'est
effectivement l'éventualité d'une dose
de proportionnelle
on en a beaucoup parlé dans les
majorités précédente avec des majorités
qui représentait pas finalement la
couleur politique du pays benjamin dire
que proportionnelle oui mais jusqu'où
parce que c'est ça la question
c'est effectivement la question c'est
bien pour cela que nous lançons le débat
que nous voulons travailler dessus
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est pas les
personnes qui sont ici qui pourront dire
le contraire qu'il y ait des partis qui
est fait des scores importants
tantôt présidentielle qu'aux
législatives et qui ne soit pas plus
représentés à l'assemblée
ça peut paraître un souci pour autant il
ne faut pas retomber dans la quatrième
république ne faut pas à voir ce qui se
passe en italie ni en allemagne donc il
faut effectivement trouvé le bon dosage
c'est sur quoi nous nous efforçons de
travailler en mai mais en même temps un
parlement qui fonctionne c'est un
parlement qui peut avoir des difficultés
à prendre des décisions est obligé de
d'écouter les autres partis et donc il
faut que les autres partis et du poids
quand même donc peu de proportionnelle
ça changerait pas grand chose si ça
changera vous avez par exemple
aujourd'hui on voit
le front national n'est pas en mesure de
constituer un groupe à l'assemblée alors
parce qu'ils sont pas capables de
fédérer autour de autrement ils
pourraient le faire on ne les empêche
pas de le faire mais aujourd'hui non pas
de groupe à l'assemblée
donc ils ont un petit peu ils ont quand
même moins de poids que d'autres que
d'autres partis aujourd'hui le but il
est là mais dans restant toutefois dans
un pays toujours toujours gouvernable
avoir une assemblée qui puisse être
cohérente sylvie beaulieu la
proportionnelle vous la voulez à quelle
hauteur
marine le pen a dit 10 12% ce serait
ridicule et méprisant oui pour nous ce
serait l'intégrale la bonne dose de
proportionnelle de toute manière pour la
gauche pour la droite pardon et macron c
zéro donc forcément nous ça nous
convient pas du tout ils en proposent
ils en proposent et enfin 10 12
c'est rien du tout quoi parce que vous
avez peur en fait que qui se passe comme
ce qui s'est passé en italie avec matteo
salvini et quand vous dites en italie
voyez comment ça se passe en italie ce
ça va bien se passer
je vois pas ça vous fait peur il ya une
espèce de phobie de la démocratie un
mépris du peuple qui vote mal donc on le
bayonne je suis pas d'accord avec ça
alain suguenot et je crois que tout ça
est très démagogiques
je le dis comme je le pense à 100 vous
avez participé à des assemblées dans
lesquelles il y avait que deux parties
représentées dans les skis et
démagogique c'est pas simplement la
proportionnelle on sait que ces demandes
et de l'extrême droite à l'extrême
gauche en passant par toutes celles et
tous ceux qui voudrait casser ce qu'est
la vème république aujourd'hui le vrai
risque est démagogique c'est surtout y
compris la diminution du nombre de
parlementaires jean marc d'une manière
très libre
vous me cassez bons plans ou il
n'empêche oui mais je crois que c'est
important quand même de le rappeler est
ce que c'est le même schéma
le premier schéma c'est de faire qui
moindre représentation quand le peuple
et moi représenté par division le peuple
hyper c'est un échec démocratique
on va parler d avoir des gardes pardon
je vous arrête là on est dans un café
c'est typiquement le genre discussions
de café du commerce
expliquez moi en quoi 577 députés ça
représente mieux le peuple que 400 parce
que pour un jeu pour les comprends pas
un instant gauthier bessens aux 17 buts
et ses caves et 500 sont 17
circonscriptions c'est qu'ils avaient
des territoires ruraux qui étaient
représentées je croyais qu'elle
suscitera sont les élus de la république
quel sera le bateleur circonspect il
sera le modèle oui mais il ya quand même
des territoires différents france vous
ne savez bien il ya les villes il ya des
métropoles il ya effectivement les zones
rurales et les zones rurales aujourd'hui
sont le plus en plus oublié on le voit
tous les jours et le fait qu'ils aient
plus de représentations si on fait
proportionnellement ce sera certainement
la population faudra bien trouver un
créneau et dans ces conditions ça veut
dire que je pense à des fleurs à deux
types de député les députés élus sur
leurs circonscriptions des députés élus
sur l'or sur louis launay n'y aura plus
de députés euros tout simplement je
prends de la côte d'or si vous en
supprimer 2 je peux vous dire que les
trois députés soins dijon arnaud binard
pointe et quand même ce que je trouve
paradoxal dans le fait d'introduire une
dose de proportionnelle
en fait la réforme constitutionnelle
c'est un bloc c'est à dire que avec
cette diminution du nombre de
parlementaires est associé aussi la
limitation du nombre d'amendements
d'entendre alors jugé que jusqu'à un
point c'est quand même le paradoxe qui a
dans cette question là de dire si la
proportionnelle y aura plus de groupes
qui sont représentés mais ils auront un
droit d'amendement qui sera beaucoup
plus faible mois pour moi effectivement
les aider ils la nation sont des doivent
être égaux en droit il n'y a pas de
raison pour qu'un électeur qui ai voté
pour la france un soumises pour la
république en marche se voit avoir un
député qui aurait moins de droit
d'amendement qu'un autre ce qui selon
lui de la même manière et dont ils
doivent avoir les mêmes droits
donc même le président de l'assemblée
nationale et contre la limitation du
droit d'amendement
et donc voilà je veux dire un moment
mais c'est une manière habile de vouloir
museler l'opposition ne pas mettre un
certain nombre de débats à l'assemblée
lieu où on est censé pouvoir discuter en
bonne intelligence
autour d'arguments et de se convaincre
c'est en parlant bien à votre micro
moi je me pose aujourd'hui la question
de savoir si tu n'as jamais cette
démocratie donc est imparfaite l
augmentation vertigineuse de
l'abstention est ce qu'elle est pas due
justement à ce mode de scrutin qui est
pendant ce temps là quelqu'un appelle
sylvie beaulieu raison téléphone voilà
vous pouvez couper votre téléphone non
mais c'est pour c'est ça qui est bien
quand on est dans un café c'est que
c'est la vraie vie du coup vous perdez
la parole et je la donne à benjamin dire
tout le temps que vous terminez votre
message benjamin dire que vous êtes
l'élu d'une circonscription où il ya
mâcon mais aussi des zones très rurales
et vous vous imaginez députés élus à la
proportionnelle donc sur une liste et
pas député d'une circonscription
ce serait différent si vous étiez ça non
mais demain il ya deux choses il ya la
proportionnelle et à la réduction du
nombre de députés restant les sur la
proportionnelle effectivement je voulais
dire que là dedans il y aura forcément
des députés qui seront issues de la va
dire du système proportionnel et qui
donc seront pas forcément lié à une
circonscription
encore une fois on l'a on lance les
débats dans faut voir de quelle manière
on le sera est ce que c par département
est ce que c'est certaines régions qui
sont plus ciblées
est ce que le travail du parlementaire
quand il est sur paris ou est-ce qu'il
en soit enfin en province est ce que
c'est le même toutes ces choses à son à
réfléchir
effectivement maintenant pour moi il est
important que le député reste le lien
entre la nation et sa circonscription
soit qu'ils le sont par contre je suis
pas du tout d'accord avec ce qui est dit
ou rien n'est fait sur le rural
aujourd'hui nous faisons beaucoup dessus
nous continuerons et même avec moins de
députés en tous les cas pour ma part je
continuerai un petit mot sur la
proportionnelle est ce qu'elle est pas
en france très mal vue en particulier à
cause de 86 lorsque françois mitterrand
bascule d'un système majoritaire à un
système de proportionnelle
alors s est vu beaulieu rigole puisque
effectivement on a beaucoup dit françois
mitterrand l'avait fait pour utiliser le
front national contre contre une victime
défaite annoncée de la gauche
aujourd'hui qui fait peur oui je pense
c'est pas ça c'est qu'alain suguenot la
proportionnelle par essence qui désigne
le député le parti politique c'est votre
classement à la proportionnelle qui fera
que vous serez moon en députés vous êtes
premier vous serez députés si vous êtes
15e vous ne serez plus députés c'est à
dire que contrairement à ce que
10 copé le président de la république
c'est un échec démocratique en ce sens
que les lecteurs qui déjà beaucoup de
difficultés pour aller voter et
s'abstient par essence c'est plus lui
qui décidera donc c'est ça que je
critique
on l'a vu dans d'autres scrutins je
pense aux régionales et compagnie si
effectivement les gens ce web est
immobilisé c'est qu'ils savent très bien
qu'ils n'ont pas leur mot à dire et que
c'est les partis politiques qui
reviennent comprendre il est en même
temps je vous renvoie la balle mais
sylvie beaulieu pourrait le faire ou
arnaud buvait natal pourrait le faire
une élection présidentielle avec le
front national face à emmanuel macron et
derrière aux législatives
très peu de sièges pour le front
national est ce qu'une démocratie peut
se retrouver nez et pas beaucoup pour la
france a soumis en fait est une
démocratie parce que tu es là dedans je
prenais pas c'est quand même une
question le créateur presse avec un
guide à ces questions à partir du moment
où vous n'avez plus le septennat
vous avez maintenant une équivalence
total la liche hâtives sur la
présidentielle dont vous avez un parti
godillot qui par définition quels que
soient les faits me politique c'est pas
une critique parce que vous avez des
tuyaux vous quand vous était député je
ne n'étais pas parce que j'avais
effectivement la volonté de rester
indépendant mais effectivement je pense
qu'une majorité d'entre nous pouvait
être godillots dans l'hypothèse où il
devait bien évidemment leur élection
élection présidentielle c'est valable
pour la proportion imaginez vous un
député élu à la proportionnelle dans la
foulée d'une présidentielle sera par
définition est obligé d'avoir le petit
doigt sur la couture du pantalon du
début par son parti politique
là on est en train de discuter de la
remise à plat des règles du jeu
démocratique
est-ce que ça serait pas aussi
intéressant qu'à un moment donné les
citoyens prennent la décision de savoir
s'ils sont d'accord avec ce changement
de règle du joue pas parce que à chaque
fois qu'il ya des réformes
constitutionnelles
jamais le peuple n'est consulté pour
savoir s'ils sont ou pas d'accord avec
la mise en place d'une dose de
proportionnelle d'un changement de
nombreux députés parce que un moment
donné il ya une greffe civique dans le
pays nous les retours qu'on peut avoir
quand on va sur les marchés où tu sais
on vous voit jamais vous êtes loin du
terrain si vous réduisez encore plus le
nombre d'élus ça n'a pas arrangé sa part
angers la proximité avec les élus et
d'autant que j'ajoute puisque en plus
vous êtes aux affaires européennes
monsieur dirks vous qui aimez bien
souvent vous caler sur les directives
européennes en europe en moyenne ya un
parlementaire pour 34 mille habitants en
france on est sur un sur 74 mille
habitants la logique voudrait si on
voulait se coller aux standards
européens carrément de doubler le nombre
de députés je pense que ça pourrait
aussi
un bon moyen d'impliquer les citoyens et
de faire lire un peu plus cette
démocratie qui pour l'instant vivre à
coups de 49,3 sous valls est maintenant
à 140 milles 140 députés c'est pas la
direction que ça prend alors vous avez
vous avez prononcé le mot le mot la
réduction du nombre de députés s'étaient
effectivement dans le programme emmanuel
macron on se dirige vers ça benjamin
dire que voilà 577 maintenant alors y en
avait moins d'ailleurs au début de la
vème république
il sait quoi la limite c'est 400 c300
est pourquoi le faire enfin est-ce que
ça c'est des économies pour le pays
alors on se souvient que le poste
économie c'était ce qu'on a annoncé
quand on a concentré les régions ça
devait faire des économies il semble que
ça en face pas est-ce que moins de
députés ça fera des économies pour la
nation ou est-ce que c'est pas là que ça
se joue
et est ce que ça peut permettre je sais
pas un meilleur travail des députés avec
plus d'assistants plus d'argent plus de
moyens c'est quoi l'idée tout à fait
alors déjà effectivement il ya un moment
donné on avait 482 députés et puis la
vème république fonctionnait très bien
vous parler d'autres pays on peut aussi
regarder le nombre d'élus locaux cadence
et autres pays ils ont beaucoup moins
d'élus locaux que nous donc il faut
aussi regarder toutes les ce règlement
est là pour vous de la loi on peut voir
toutes les strates quand même ce qui
important oui mais quand on est
justement le parlement est là pour voter
la loi
il est là pour voter la loi et vous
demandez tout à l'heure à être encore
plus présents sur le terrain chose que
nous faisons puisqu'il est important de
faire remonter les choses et nous
continuerons de le faire maintenant
pourquoi réduire le nombre de députés
liddell et où elle est de dire nous
recentrons justement le député sur son
rôle la loi de législatif contrôler et
évaluer pour cela on veut lui donner
plus de moyens mais comment lui donner
les moyens et donc moins de marchés
moins deux rendez vous avec les
administrés moins de temps passé à
écouter les doléances des gens je
continue lang lang
non mais je continue juste l'explication
donc là-dessus donner plus de moyens en
réduisant nombre de députés pour aller
sur ces je reprends donc légiférer
contre les évaluer bien sûr qu'il fera
toujours continuer d'aller sur sur le
terrain et sur les marchés et cetera je
vous disais tout à l'heure chose qu'on
fait qu'on fait déjà beaucoup et que je
fais à longueur de temps
c'est pour ça qu'il ya peut-être des
choses à voir encore une fois rien
n'était écrit rien n'est définitif
est ce que quand on parle d'une
réduction il faudrait pas voir la
superficie également des départements et
avoir quelque chose de cohérent par
rapport à cela dans tous les cas nous
travaillons dessus pour prendre tous les
axe en compte on a parlé pendant la
campagne d'une forme de clientélisme
par exemple quand on parlait de la
réserve parlementaire est ce que réduire
le nombre de députés et les déconnecter
de leur circonscription
c'est pas une façon d'arrêter avec le
député qui défend l' usine de chez lui
le député qui défend la production de
l'élevage de chez lui et des gens qui
finalement ne sont pas des gens qui
votent la loi comme le disait benjamin
dire mais le le député vote la loi mais
quelle loi s'il est complètement
déconnectés du terrain le rôle du député
dans la définition personnelle mais je
crois que j'étais pas le seul c'est
effectivement de faire remonter si
possible quelques fois le bon sens du
terrain au niveau national pour éviter
de voter n'importe quoi c'est aussi ça
le député le jour où le déconnecter il
peut avoir le rôle effectivement
législatif du contrôle du gouvernement
est de faire loi faut pas se leurrer les
députés ne font plus la loi tout le
monde le sait ça date pas d'aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que par définition quels
sont les problèmes mais qui les boudent
ont-ils jamais fait sous la vème répond
on l'a fait je les fais en effet en 1994
sous edouard balladur
je suis l'un des auteurs de la réforme
sur les entreprises en difficulté
notamment du mandataire ad'hoc donc on
le faisait à l'époque avait des
propositions de loi qui aboutissait oui
apic des projets de loi qui comme leurs
noms l'indiquent viennent du
gouvernement et l'inflation législative
fait que par les chiens un député
aujourd'hui il suit quand il est
spécialisé certains dossiers il
n'empêche que il ne peut pas participer
véritablement l'élaboration de la loi
donc aujourd'hui si effectivement il ne
peut plus représenter un territoire
parce qu'il n'a plus cette vocation la
moins ils seront nombreux mois il rate
territoires représentés je crois que
c'est une aberration
non le vrai problème est ce que vous
croyez que les françaises et les
français attendent aujourd'hui de
réformes cruciale vous pensez que c'est
ça qu'ils demandent ils demandent entre
guillemets qu'on leur apporte des vraies
réponses sur l'histoire de siéger
j'avais prévu les sondages par la fin
d'émission de je vous en parlais pas des
sondages dessus quand même neuf français
sur dix sont pour la réduction du nombre
de députés on a posé la question il
répond bien sûr parce que 58% pour une
dose de proportionnelle 86% pour la
limitation chèrement j'appelle la
démagogie mais j'espère que le
gouvernement d'aujourd'hui parce que
vous l'avez demandé
j'espère que le gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui à d'autres réponses
apportées aux françaises et aux français
que de répondre ce que tout le monde
effectivement pu attendre c'est à dire
par démagogie on dit ça fera des
économies
quels seront les économistes et votre
question tout à l'heure j'apporterai
poussier aucune économie réalisée il ya
simplement un défaut de représentativité
du citoyen par rapport à l'état
bibeau les moins deux députés ça fait
partie des choses que vous demandiez mon
député moins de cinq heures parce que là
on a un député un exécuté mais aussi les
sénateurs va bien que 7,7
proportionnelle pose de gros problèmes
puisque on en parle depuis tellement
longtemps qu'on voit bien que c'est très
très difficile à mettre en place
on parle d'une dose de proportionnelle
depuis plusieurs mandatures on a eu
plusieurs présidents on a eu sa roue on
a vu tout le monde parle de cette dose
de proportionnelle et on la voit jamais
arriver donc où elle vraiment le
problème je retourne la question c'est
plutôt moi qui pose des questions mais
voilà mais couverts fois c'était moi
donc où est le problème c'est que
justement on n'arrive pas trop à trouver
la manière de museler une certaine
partie de la population donc avec cette
proportionnelle un peu coincé même avec
10 ou 12 ou 13%
ce sera ce sera du pipeau c'est
complètement inutile ans n'a aucun sens
arnault viennent à terme ce serait bien
moins député qui travaille beaucoup avec
beaucoup de pouvoirs de contrôle et de
et de régulation et moins de députés
encore une fois je le redis je pense pas
que ce soit ce soit ce soit vraiment le
le débat sur le fait de réduire le
nombre député mois pour moi là vraiment
la question qui est vraiment posé c'est
le sens de la logique de la constitution
de la vème république
vous parliez de sondages favorables au
projet de réforme constitutionnelle mais
lorsqu'on avait fait il ya un an jour
pour jour la marche pour la 6ème
république
il y avait une majorité de français à 80
% qui était pour la mise en place d'une
6ème république est d'aller vers plus de
représentativité plus de démocratie donc
les sondages on peut leur fait dire ce
qu'on veut c'est un instant de l'opinion
moi je continue le débat politique sur
le fait que le problème du parlement
actuellement c'est qu'il n'est qu'une
chambre d'enregistrement des desiderata
du président de la république parce que
le problème est là c'est que c'est que
le président décide propose la loi les
députés en marche avec la majorité
pléthorique où votent comme un seul
homme
est-ce que c'est pas la cinquième qui
est conçu comme ça voilà tu as fait
c'est à dire les choses
la cinquième elle a été conçue comme ça
pour que
les lois passées très clairement mais
c'est pour ça que nous nous avons
dénoncé cette logique depuis un certain
nombre d'années et on n'est pas les
seuls
le passage à la 6ème république
une représentation plus un parlementaire
avec une implication populaire plus
grande et référendum d'initiative
citoyenne la révocation des élus c'est à
mon avis le bon sens pour faire respirer
cette démocratie qui est étouffé par les
49 3 les ordonnances et le fait qu'on
n'ait jamais notre mot à dire lors de
l'élection
on a fait plusieurs émissions avec
arnaud montebourg dans des cafés sur la
6ème république
et depuis elle n'a toujours pas de sens
benjamin dire que vous la rampe sur ce
que j'entends aujourd'hui encore une
fois nous suivons exactement le
programme pour lequel nous avons été élu
emmanuel macron été élu et nous députés
nous avons été élus alors pourquoi
adroit je te survivrai politique je peux
finir merci donc puisque nous suivons et
que et que l'exécutif suis exactement le
programme
pourquoi ne pas voter ce qui était dit
c'est exactement ce que nous voulions
par contre je peux vous retourner
d'ailleurs la chose les amendements qui
sont proposés par la france un sou ni
sont toujours co signée par l'ensemble
de la france insoumise est ce que tout
le monde si monsieur mélenchon je sais
pas on peut se poser la question est
maintenant pour ce qui est pour ce qui
est du rôle du député handball oui mais
c'est quand même ça vous nous reprochez
de suivre le gouvernement est quelque
part tout le monde suit votre tête de
mes contiennent maintenant composé
d'éléments qui vont dans le bon sens on
est capable de buter attentes argument
de poids pour cela mais maintenant je
vais je vais juste finir pour ce qui est
des députés godillots podz de godillots
aujourd'hui nous sommes plusieurs
députés avoir fait une proposition de
loi pour la gratuité scolaire pour les
personnes en dessous du seuil de propos
très de pauvreté c'est quelque chose qui
vient deux députés de la majorité qui ne
vient pas du tout du gouvernement et
nous sommes en discussion là dessus donc
aujourd'hui le travail parlementaire et
auguste ou alors on se retrouvera pour
ça est ce qu'il y aura au bout un texte
une loi est-ce qu'on peut quand on est
député aujourd'hui faire ce qu'alain
suguenot décrivez tout à leur faire
arriver un texte jusqu'à la loi
exactement nous puisque là nous sommes
en train de travailler dessus ça mais je
me donner rendez vous au moment où ça
allait payer quoi ça fait ça fait neuf
mois qu'on est en place et je pense
qu'au niveau des réformes
on a quand même été assez fort depuis le
début et vous voyez bien que nous
continuerons donc oui dans les temps
pour le faire alors un petit 1
un mot sur l'assemblée alors ça c'était
pas dans le programme d' emmanuel macron
et ses sorties ces dernières semaines et
ça concerne le fonctionnement de
l'assemblée
c'est la limitation du nombre
d'amendements en fonction du poids du
groupe puisque effectivement c'est pas
pour tout le monde alors c'est vrai que
l'opinion publique le français de moyens
il entend parfois avant on a déposé cinq
mille amendements l'opposition a déposé
cinq mille amendements contre un texte
ça donne pas toujours une très bonne
image de l'assemblée est ce que c'est
pas une bonne solution parce que vous
l'avez ça c'est le crime
ce contre les démocraties à
parlementaire par définition s'il n'a
plus le droit d'amender un projet de loi
excusé qui exhibe en plus de
propositions
il a le droit de poser 200 amendements
identiques à la virgule
il ya eu des modifications ça vous parle
du passé parce que ces examens mais ya
déjà eu déjà depuis quelques mois des
tur une limite les amendements pour
éviter effectivement les abus rld était
d'accord il s'agit pas de changer une
virgule ou de poser tous les mêmes
amendements mais le fait même d'évoquer
la possibilité de modifier de diminuer
de manière très sensible la capside
amendements des parlementaires
le parlementaire sert plus à rien quoi
il sert y sert effectivement elle dit
en même temps quand il est dans
l'opposition il sert à rien de toute
façon aujourd'hui je dis oui c'est ça
qui est un peu dommage ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas mais dans
l'hypothèse où le débat démocratique est
confisqué par quelques-uns a brillé par
une majorité qu'on accepte pas justement
la capside amendement effectivement là
pour le coup il n'existe plus et c'est
raison pour laquelle je comprends très
bien les difficultés qu'on peut avoir et
que les groupes minoritaires l'assemblée
nationale puisse aujourd'hui s'exprimer
clairement sur les amis vous nous coupez
absolument la possiblité voulu couper la
possibilité d'être élu le coupé la
possibilité par amendement de modifier
ce projet slam proportionnelle pas tout
à fait parce que oui mais plus posé mais
à 12% de proportions rejoint ce qui a
été dit je suis la dette vers sert
d'appât pour ces deux quelle qu'elle
soit mais à 12% c'est se moquer du monde
ont déjà bien d'accord simplement si
vous supprimez l'amendement vous
supprimez l'opposition mais vous
supprimez surtout la majorité j'étais le
méchant députés anti des fientes ya deux
piges été contre mon groupe et j'ai
réussi effectivement à faire voter
l'assemblée nationale contre l'avis de
ma propre majorité
c'est fini si vous n'avez plus la
liberté d'amendements incapacité de
faire vous n'exprimez plus le député n'a
pas un mandat impératif
le député met dans une famille politique
son courage à lui c'est de représenter
les françaises et les français quand il
estime que c'est nécessaire a jamais
dire
alors commencer vécu ça en ce moment
dans les couloirs de l'accent non
aujourd'hui on recentre tous
l'importance et l'efficacité et
aujourd'hui on manque on manque
d'efficacité et la réactivité quand on
voit à quai à quai à quelle vitesse le
monde avance tout avance et à quelle
vitesse avance la santé est quand même
un souci quand on sait qu'on va
commencer de lancer un texte et que
simplement au moins peut-être qu'un an
plus tard les décrets d'application
seront tombés et encore en aura de la
chance il y a un souci donc forcément il
ya des choses à revoir maintenant il ya
des choses effectivement qu'ils ne
doivent pas être anti démocratique le
droit d'amendement c'est quelque chose
de fondamental pour un député c'est sûr
et encore une fois il ya des choses
qu'on pût des bases de travail qui ont
été lancées mais que d'heureux dit de le
mettre en rapport entre le nombre de
députés dans un groupe et le nombre
d'amendements
ça ça me paraît compliqué par contre
françois de rugy président de
l'assemblée qui est quand même pas des
syriens opposés au président et premier
ministre a dit qu'il était contre cette
mesure
c'est ce que je vous explique que ça ça
paraît compliqué et quelque part
antidémocratique et quelque part on
pourrait penser que on pourrait penser
que mais non mais que local au pot que
l'opposition va même pouvoir mettre plus
d'amendements à des certainement ces
contrats passés on peut l'apprendre mais
laissez moi parlons de la cantine de
type erp de type d'avant demain il y à
d'autres types d'amendements il y a les
amendements on va retrouver trois cents
fois le même amendement est gelée vécu
depuis que je suis à l'assemblée ça ne
sert strictement à rien il y a les
amendements qui seront des cavaliers
législatifs ne sert strictement que vous
faire glisser une mesure dans un autre
cas il y à il y à il y alegria des
amendements qui n'ont strictement rien à
voir arrivent à travailler à la ccbe
beaulieu pourrait poser votre question
c'est quoi j'ai envie de vous dire quand
on vous écoute on se dit ça y est ils
vont trier les amendements donc les bons
d'un côté les mauvais qui vous plaisent
pas de l'autre et là on part vers
quelque chose de pas rigolo du tout
l'amendement c'est quoi c'est un moyen
de positionner un avis sur un texte si
on en ici on limite le nombre on est on
est on est confiné dans quelque chose
qui n'est pas rigolo du tout on part
vers une librairie liberté d'expression
qui est complètement bafouée
et ça c'est autant d'autant que l'odeur
de la tam et benjamin d'hirson je suis
quand même assez assez opposée au cias
qui était dit par par monsieur hulot sur
le fait qu'un groupe d'opposition que
des députés de l'opposition ne servent à
rien moi je crois vraiment au débat
politique je crois que je même dans le
cadre là moi je ponds je pense ou parler
l'expérience d'expérience moi je suis
convaincu que sur des mesures de bon
sens qui peuvent faire qui peut faire
sens et c'est à cette essence d'aider
des lois des projets de loi qui avaient
été massées dès la puberté la bande bon
ça sert plus à rien oui non mais mais je
ne défends pas le réduction du nombre
d'amendements dont on a compris je
l'emmène qu'elle va peut-être pas être
très très important le texte on apprend
carrément que mes gars de l'aviron
marche c'est presque fini
quand vous quand vous restez jusqu'à 3h
ou 4h du matin dans l'hémicycle pour
deux amendements
il se passe quoi il se passe que vous
disiez depuis tout à l'heure de
dépistage en proposant le moment le 4
heures du matin ne fut pas nous demander
tous depuis tout à l'heure c'est quand
même c'est l'importance de les lui qu'on
voit l'importance de l'élu est pas
d'intérêt d'antiparlementarisme il se
passe quoi à cause de tous ces
amendements ceux qui ne servent à rien
pas les autres qui ne servent à rien il
se passe justement qu'on reste jusqu'à
trois ou quatre heures dans l'hémicycle
et maintenant je comprends depuis que je
suis élu comment on peut arriver un
hémicycle vide
lorsqu'on doit être en même temps dans
l'hémicycle en commission sur le terrain
préparé
peu importe ce qu'on aura à préparer
comme loi pour demain et on nous demande
en même temps d'être jusqu'à 4 heures du
matin dans l'hémicycle pour ces
amendements qui n'ont pas de sens
donc là vous favorisez
l'antiparlementarisme non cela ce qui
n'a rien de mieux et élus dont je sais
pas si vous entendez la musique qui
commence mais on nous dit que c'était la
fin de l'émission que c'est bien
découvre le métier député faudra
l'expliquer merci à tous les cas je
remercie actuelle quatre des prévenus
débattre on le voit ce débat ne fait que
commencer on verra sous quelle forme
il se poursuivra
merci bon dimanche au revoir
[Musique]
oui